i specifically use twitter as a forum  almost like a journal of philosophy for  me  but there's a reason i publish  those quotes instead of keep them to  myself  and that's to hold myself accountable  because i want to be the person i tell  people that i am  so when i put something out to the  universe that  instigates a conversation about  philosophy or  tackles an uncomfortable subject  it makes me accountable  when i tell you i love my wife it makes  me accountable she knows i love her she  doesn't need me to tell you but it makes  me accountable and i think that's  important for me as a system of checks  and balances for the rest of the world  to keep me in line  and i just think nowadays  we have the freedom of speech  but we don't have  any accountability a lot of times for  that